ron has any number of publications about
Vietnam but my favorite book that he did
both Vietnam for dummies yeah he said he
was including himself into next but a
whole variety of publications on that
topic so he comes as the expert on
vietnam war experiences that he's had in
Vietnam and then Tracy Weiss and I got
to know each other a couple of years ago
because a book project that I was
working on that just was published
earlier this year called Cleo of the
classroom teaching us women and Tracy
contributed a chapter and then we
together a story so she has done a
project of the organization screams and
she was written in many venues both
implications on lot of publications i
encourage you to google off both of them
because i'm not doing justice to all
their accomplishments but there's really
interesting things that you can find on
the website and historical history
cooperative
great I we're going to do this as a team
taught adventure so i'll be doing the
first part and then Ron and I together
will be you in second part as I made my
way up from the train from penn station
today i remembered about seven or eight
years ago I did a lot of work in New
York with American social history
project at CUNY and a lot of work with
New York area Teachers and it was
wonderful to fail the dynamism of New
York when you come from a small town
like Lancaster little different pace
there I know from the work that I've
done with teachers how intense a
workshop like this is when you come in
day after day after day all day long so
just to give us a bit of an advantage if
folks will be willing to share one of
the most important things that you've
learned that has kind of changed how you
think about teaching Vietnam over the
course of the past couple days anybody
Internet yes thank you your name too I
don't know we have time to do
comprehensive introductions but at least
we'll get some sense of where you teach
and what you're what you're learning so
far what resources have been helpful
what insights from some of the different
presenters yes
one thing on the first day at social
slave department at the William and Mary
came and discuss this piece of
documentary and how student to do that
it's a authentic source of information
and they don't take they look at it
objective or they they viewed as
objective looking at it like they do
traditional Hollywood films and the need
to have kind of rigorous protocols for
interrogating evidence that students
don't always think about that same way
that we might anybody else sure they're
more than two insights anything else you
can remember a week from now when you go
when you're finished with this whole
other ways of displaying importance of
selecting evidence which is the main
task one of the main task of historians
what else give you another minute for
the introverted people to compose their
thoughts what we're going to do is we're
going to have a short presentation on
thinking about how to use visual
evidence what are some of the issues
around that will practice as a group
with some examples and then we'll be
asking you to do exactly what peg was
talking about to make some selections
and create your own very very short
narrative of particular aspect of
Vietnam so let me begin if we think
about visual literacy one of the things
that we might begin to consider is how a
broad range of evidence and in
particular the kinds of things that many
of you mentioned already comics posters
photographs
still images as well as moving images
how these can serve to expand historical
imagination of our students so we think
about visibility and the problem of
evidence we can imagine that on several
levels one is simply the very first
comment in the United States many people
and I imagine many high school
classrooms look at the Vietnam War from
the perspective of US history from the
perspective of American citizens and not
necessarily think of it as a global
phenomenon and think about it from the
perspective of the French think about it
from the perspective of the Vietnamese
themselves so there's the visibility of
historic subject and there's also the
question of using visual evidences to
make that representation so what we're
going to do today is talk about why
bother with comics or photographs or
visual evidence what are some ways that
we can effectively help students to
learn how to do that that's the how
question and then at the end after we've
done some very short mini visual
narratives so what what does a visual
interpretation get us that a regular
print interpretation does not get us so
starting with why I imagine that many of
you are familiar with the work of the
Center for history new media at George
Mason but let me just take a poll how
many of you have used any of their
resources okay certainly some folks what
I want to do today before we get into
Vietnam I mentioned France or the French
a minute ago is talk about one of their
projects which is imaging the French
Revolution most of what we had known
about the French Revolution as you may
know came from the documentary evidence
in particular from the pamphlets but we
begin to look at images we begin to
understand something different about
that historic phenomenon for example as
this one of the scholars said it was
involved in this senator history new
media project to bring to the web a
series of images on the French
Revolution what it lets us do is to see
what happened not just to hear about it
and to try to visualize it ourselves but
actually to see what
happened why does this matter for
today's students as we know students
today live in a visually saturated
culture even though they're surrounded
by images we know that they're not
necessarily adept at interrogating
images but if we look at images
sometimes we see things in the image
that we somehow did not see in the
documentary evidence or maybe it was
there but we weren't skilled enough to
read between the lines to see it so for
example if you were interested in
looking for the participation of women
in the French Revolution you could study
the documentary evidence but you could
also study the visual evidence and you
might get some different insights from
each of those bodies of evidence I let's
talk for a minute about of it some
extent you're on some images that I use
in my class in US history this example
that came from the without sanctuary
website of lynching it's very powerful
website some of you I imagine have them
have you sit in your classrooms when I
talk with students about what they learn
from this I highlighted one of the
images you might be able to tell from
where you're sitting that this is a
photograph that includes some young
children some young girls many students
think about lynching is something that
happens under the cover of darkness at
night you know people wear robes sheets
things to mask their identity when
they're confronted with images that show
that these events took place in broad
daylight these events were not hidden
people were making no efforts to conceal
themselves and that some of these
lynchings were spectacles that in some
cases there were special railroad cars
that were organized to transport people
to the scene of lynching so they weren't
secret they weren't hidden in other
words visual evidence lets us see
something that we might not see if we
were reading a documentary account of a
lynching for example why use images
because images like print sources get us
at the center of historical enterprise
which is a focus from the students side
that things that are most concrete
people and organizations this
actors places insights being able to
visualize you think about a college
campus if I were to ask people what does
college campus look like we have 30 some
people in this room would have 30
different pictures of college campuses I
think about project I did at LaGuardia
walking in that block long building and
feeling the homme and recognizing that
there are people in that building who
come from all parts of the world that's
a very different picture and a very
different experience than the
residential college kind of residential
kind of commuter college where I teach
at in central Pennsylvania so places
insights it's especially important be
able to see them events and dates and
ideas ideas in some respects might be
the hardest things to visualize and yet
if we were to say to you come up with a
picture of nationalism come to the
picture of colonialism if we would ask
our students to go out and bring back a
picture that represents an idea it would
be probably very provocative exercising
we might get some overlap in the images
that came back into the classroom but
would probably get some very different
perspectives as well so we use images
because it helps us to do history better
another reason is because of the student
population we work with I've already
mentioned they live in a visually
saturated culture these are just some
examples that they are constantly
looking at images creating images and
the other thing that they're doing as
well is sound in oral I'm not
necessarily the completely abandoned the
written culture but they're written
culture takes place with their two
things they're two thumbs so how how can
we begin to use images in this case in
particular to interrogate the Vietnam
War we need protocols with examination
of visual evidence let me try another
little poll on you history matters
website gateway to US history how many
folks have heard of it okay again a few
folks if you are familiar with this
website history matters gmu.edu they
have a feature called making sense of
documents
that is very very helpful oral history
films maps numbers letters diaries
advertisements popular music in
photography and when if you go to that
website and you click on those links it
gives you some ideas of how to proceed
in a rigorous and systematic way rather
than a kind of haphazard approach for
example since we're going to be looking
at photographs today in our presentation
I want to did a screen shot of Jim
curtis's presentation on making sense of
documentary photography each of these
has the same setup there's a getting
started there's questions to ask which
are at the center and then there's
additional resources to use to follow up
on so if we think about what kinds of
questions we're looking at photographs
what kind of questions should we ask we
know what questions to ask when we're
looking at a document a written document
so the questions that we ask about a
photograph or visual document are
similar but there are some important
differences who created the image is
similar to who created the document why
and for whom was the object or image
produce the question of audience how we
don't always think so much about how
when we think about written documents
but how was image produced what was the
technology involved what kind of
technology would be accessible to
different parts of the population what
can companion images tell us the context
and this is also important for print
document so we don't usually think about
it how was the document the image the
object presented recirculated circulated
then recirculated and received one of
the most common phrases among our young
people i think is the notion of remix
what you think about in terms of music
in particular but how images keep coming
back and we'll talk a little bit more
about this later in the presentation in
different formats with different frames
the same image with a different frame
yields a different meaning and that's
part of our job here today is to figure
out how can we get at the question of
meaning I don't know how many of you
took any art history classes in your
lifetime but I remember as a first-year
student being in a large lecture hall
introduction to art and the method that
I remembered was the instructor up there
with two at that point slide projector
so you know how old I am slide
projectors right you know managing them
one hand on each each control the point
about that that I don't think I got as a
young undergraduate but I think I have
some appreciation for now is this idea
of juxtaposition in other words play
scene in that case tues our history
slides two paintings for example side by
side because that lets us see some
complexity that we don't often see for
only looking at one thing and one of the
examples I do my classroom every
semester is I have a willing student who
will volunteer stand in front of the
room and I ask the other students to
describe that student so you know what
she or she is wearing have a hat they've
boots they've jeans they've khakis and
they're pretty willing to do this I'm
gonna get a second volunteer make the
first one stay up there I get a second
volunteer to go up in right away they
start comparing so-and-so's hair is long
so and so's hair is short so and so is
wearing blue jeans so and so's wearing
shorts and I say to them juxtaposition
doesn't guarantee deep and sophisticated
analysis but it inclines us in that
direction if we have only one thing
we're often going to simply report on it
or describe it but once we have two
things we usually become much more alert
to both similarity into difference and
so that's one of the principles we want
to think about in using visual evidence
is to go back what can companion images
tell us some of you I'm know are
familiar with the Migrant Mother
photograph and the fact that if you go
back to the archive and you see not just
the migrant mother that's plastered
everywhere in our culture but the
migrant mother as a series of
photographs if we can begin to change
your mind about the conditions of that
photograph in the meaning of that
photograph so we're going to ask you to
do later on the presentation as I said I
warned you we're going to ask you to
make a little visual narrative of your
own working with some other folks
if we think about a slide term that I
use with my students when I have them
produce visual narratives is this notion
of a complex slide which is simply the
idea of the two students end up in front
of the room comparing and contrasting
that what I want them to do on the slide
is to put two pieces of evidence ever
rule my classroom when the bullets are
flying no one is safe so I don't usually
let students do bulleted presentations
but then they have to put on the slide
two pieces of evidence could be two
images it could be two quotes it could
be an image and a quote and it's up to
them to select the evidence but then the
point becomes when you have these two
pieces of evidence that could point in
different directions then your job as
historian is to reconcile them you leave
the workshop tonight you go home summary
says oh how was your workshop today you
have some little tidbit from the day
we're all in the same room we're
experiencing more or less the same
workshop and yet our accounts what we're
going to select get back to it peg said
we're going to select from the day is
going to be different and so we can send
students to the archive they can get
different evidence but then their job
and your job today will be to interpret
that evidence another resource which may
be more familiar than either the Center
for history new media or history matters
of national archives how many folks have
gone to the national archive site
they've great resources for students and
teachers among them are their analysis
worksheets they 14 document for artifact
cartoon Mapp motion picture photograph
poster and sound recording so they're
wonderful resources are already out
there for you there in a format that if
you want to modify it for your class you
can but you can use them straight off
the web and we'll be using those today
as well okay the three focuses the foci
I guess you could say I'm observation
inference in question many times our
students want to jump right away to
number two we said well whoa whoa wait
slow down look before you infer or
question or conclude so getting back to
the issue of how we interpret visual
evidence I'm going to turn a podium over
to Ron and we're going to talk about
some examples of that
I'll pass this up do it is a beginning
phase of this is to ask you when you
think of the Vietnam War what is the
image that pops into your mind or what
type of image pops into your mind just
to get a sense I yeah yes sir okay so
jungle warfare that the deep Triple
Canopy jungles and the soldier is sort
of trotting through that
right generated general loan so the
image of this is the June 63 the
Buddhist monk protesting note in ziam or
a general law loans assassinate or not
well execution of the DC suspect which
is very controversial image as well in
terms of that ok so the turmoil that
occurred within the United States as a
result of America's involvement in
Vietnam and sort of that the fabric of
American society a traveling in front of
many people's eyes and questioning why
these things are happening said the
other famous picture of the young girl
who has been hit by napalm and is burned
running down the dirt road and the
question of this is sort of becomes a
symbol of the anti-war movement a
summation or I keep constant
assassinated the execution of the VC
suspect these are really images at
galvanizing anti-war movement absolutely
as the war progresses and it's
interesting that's interesting
observation a lot of the GIS who wore
the peace signs didn't necessarily wear
them because they were opposed to the
war or opposed to their involvement in
the war but that was just a sign of the
times as well so they had different
reasons for doing that but yeah there's
a there's a wonderful documentary of
speaking of documentaries on case on and
there's some questions that are asked
about do you know why are you wearing
the peace sign and you're sitting here
in a marine and case on things like well
I'm doing because everyone else is doing
it oh absolutely some were very very
much very much absolutely and it's a
very very powerful symbol as well so but
it spreads the the you know the reasons
behind that yeah
absolutely and I think just in this very
brief extra so yeah go ahead sorry in
the documentary they showed the general
ball execution the actual execution that
yielded that iconic image and the
juxtaposition of those two is really
profound is that having seen that image
so many times but then to see him in the
casual way that he points the gun fires
he's walking it's really disturbing it
was it was very disturbing for many in
the United States who didn't understand
the story behind it absolutely and it's
a longer story and a very controversial
story in terms of what was but that
image really begins to capture what many
individuals in the United States how
they sort of experience the war and
began to express their their feelings
emotions about the war I think just in
looking at this briefly that reinforces
a lot of what Tracy just said about how
we we look at images and how we
interpret images and the significance of
that and what we're going to do is we
have three sets of images that we're
going to look at and work on and this
this first image I think we'll go
through if I might we'll go through the
worksheet and maybe we'll just do it as
a group look at the the different things
the the observations the inference and
the questions and kind of get a sense of
what you make of this image but you know
as you say one of the other things that
we can think about in terms of images
that certainly comes across with the
lynching example I gave and also our
conversation about images that we think
of we think of Vietnam as educators we
talk often about being sensitive to what
our students bring into the classroom
particularly to the prior knowledge but
i think they also we know they bring in
emotions as well about all kinds of
things particularly about difficult to
discuss things race being one example
and so one of the things that images do
I think sometimes more powerfully than
print sources do is touch into those
deeply held
beliefs and convictions those kind of
emotions and those beliefs not just
their knowledge because sometimes the
feeling and the belief and the
conviction are at odds with the
knowledge and so it's helpful again to
think about this principle of juxta
bisson juxtaposition we're not just
juxtaposing a photograph in a
documentary source we're often in the
process juxtaposing belief and knowledge
and emotion and the Vietnam War is you
probably already know and experience
over the last couple days will challenge
all the beliefs and all the emotions
that that you bring into it and will
continue to challenge those those ideas
as you will find them and shape them as
you teach them to your students so we
will take this image will do this as a
group because I'm not going to give you
any background to the image but i'll
tell you a little story about it maybe
after we finish this part of the
exercise but as you look at this image
what are the observables here what draws
you yeah thank you ok so we have do we
want to buy my quadrant was that the
idea or doesn't matter isn't it just ok
ok so yeah just you know take it take a
min or two and take a look at it so
certainly race yeah ok ok so certainly
there's a difference in a tire and
that's so good observable is going yes
sir kind of the juxtaposition of old and
young it was sort of an older gentleman
in the background that then is small why
right Franz ok so old and young
absolutely so what else do you see yeah
no yeah all right absolutely which
raises that question will get into the
inverters of why well let's do yeah they
look like they're in the middle of doing
something or on their way in there's
activity it's not staged photo yeah
there's there's motion there's an
activity something's going there's
action ok so there's certainly the yet
there's a there's a military component
here they're actually both Navy but but
there's the rosette no military
component
image the way that the gentleman the
left is dress looks like he could serve
some kind of religious purpose or
ceremonial purpose and this woman on the
right side of our to tell she is the
head what she's wearing in her head I
don't know
okay so certainly we can observe there
is there is a religious component
attached to the image okay so there you
can observe a clash of cultures I guess
maybe we didn't Fuhrer clash of cultures
with Jim's inferred you could probably
do both by suppose but absolutely but
there's there's there is the the
appearance of language difficulty and
certainly there's a difference of
culture ya know okay but she's in it
within that action there's caring there
seems to be possessions involved okay
yeah any other descriptions yeah
anything else that you see it's hard it
you're right but it's hard we we do
every one skips that first step and I
did too when I first look at the image
so
okay certainly had the facial
expressions i think tell potentially a
story here as well yes sir absolutely
says she is stage center she's the focus
of the imaging well the gesture and a
lot of people draws you towards the the
arm it towards this piece in the
photograph which is undefined and then
you just got this arms who else is sort
of in this scene that we're not see is a
possibility of cropping or yes it within
that sort of the action or the motions
is moving in this direction looking at
that person whoever it is well we
observe yeah yeah we go in terms of the
observables I mean she's she's I think
the expression is well that's what drew
me to the picture and when I first
looked at it so and then in terms of
inference what would we we've already
begun to sort of infer what the picture
means yes sir he's trying to get
instructions but
alright let's focus on him for a second
then we have the the lieutenant in the
sort of center left of the image when we
could infer that he's perhaps annoyed
what else could we infer from that from
looking at that so I think you can make
many different inferences yes
anybody ever served in the Navy here
they would never say they're well fed
maybe but yeah but you're right i mean
that if that says so we can we can infer
that that perhaps she's a refugee and in
this observation who we have a
difference in in how we observe it he
doesn't appear annoyed in your sense he
appears to be helping trying to guide
this individual this refugee along okay
so urgency but it could be a noise I
mean we don't know but it could be noise
could be urgency it could be it could be
what else could a translator perhaps so
he's doing his duty since of his job it
could be a doctor absolutely this
gentleman here okay that's the beauty of
the image you know a picture is worth a
thousand words I tell my students and
then I tell them not to give me five
pictures because they'll fail for their
essay but in this case this picture was
actually worth a book when I first
looked at it but yeah you have the image
at the Vietnamese jungle in the
background he could be upset he could be
smiling he could be trying to do the job
of the people up front you know we don't
really know exactly what it is
what do you think he was hoping to
capture what would you infer from that
but the individuals taking the picture I
can't tell you it was a pio pio officer
so Navy public affairs officer was
saying in the picture I'll start to get
some pants yeah so we can refer this is
an important event that's occurring
perhaps it's worthy of being documented
yeah okay I can infer this important but
that's just make my own personal bias
okay so it could that the religion then
we can refer the importance of of the
event via religion I think we over here
then okay so going to the exact same
thing I thought it was a public
relations image I know that there were a
lot of images at the time portraying
sort of benevolent American paternalism
and this seems defeated to that that
America is the generous giant that will
come in and serve people or in need okay
what do you think the image was taken
can you get any any sense of that any
inferences from the actual image okay so
we have a 54 black and white so do you
think it's it's got to be a little bit
older so certainly the question you know
when was it taken is for historians as a
crucial question what are some other
questions that this image raises for you
other things should need to understand
before you could be more determined or
decisive in your interpretation yeah
okay okay when and where
just because we're seeing a black gotta
check yet so you got a jumpin that's
right you mean black and white cameras
sir we're around four they're still
around although no one uses them
remember yeah okay so what what is the
source of the interaction is there a
verbal interaction is it simply a motion
interaction perhaps even the language of
the interaction potentially question to
ask them then the significance of that
we had the WHO and the where as well
what else because if you think about the
what of the picture what what's the
action there could be other evidence
that would provide answers to that I go
back again because a teacher
african-american history example of
lynching having students read a
transcript in which a man who's being
interviewed recalls a lynching that had
taken place in his childhood and then I
have them listen to the audio clip and
we talked about the difference is that
what you hear in the audio clip is a man
banging his hand on the table you hear
the man's kind of stuttering in a speech
you hear the pause you hear a whole set
of feelings that you wouldn't
necessarily get reading the transcript
you could imagine those you could infer
some of those so that there could be
some other evidence that would answer
some of these questions how would you go
about trying to find answers to some of
the questions that we've raised here
comes Ronnie throws this photograph in
your face and says okay you know tell me
about this what does this mean the
thesis word that we use some time with
our students what's the thesis of your
essay what's the thesis of this
photograph what's the interpretation
where would we go to find more answers
to some of the questions that were
raised and the beauty of the thesis is
Vietnam is a very visual war is that
there are no wrong answers as we tell
our students you know it's very
subjective in this process and you could
as you've had in terms of your
observations and your inferences you
have come up with some very different
stories to what this picture
might mean so what would be what would
be the thesis some of you knowing that
you cannot add give no wrong answer yeah
ok so this yeah the the picture revolves
around an evacuation perhaps ok ok so if
ya if religion has a role than what is
that role of religion and we could look
at at the Vietnamese the Roman Catholic
Church in Vietnam while it existed and
perhaps what role it played in a
potential an evacuation you'd think to
about where did this photograph come
from we know that it's part of the
presentation today we've talked a little
bit about the National Archive a
protocol for analyzing photographs did
this photograph come from a public
repository could we go and actually
ourselves look at this photograph are
there a series of photographs that we
can look at that were taken at that same
time um who was the photographer or is
this a photograph that ron has in his
file in his office at millersville which
I do but that's not where it is urgent
well one of the things that if we look
at this image and I again I this image
was the the catalyst for a book that I
wrote called Operation passage of
freedom which was in 1954 54 255 and
when I looked at the image knowing
absolutely nothing about this what
struck me was that just the face that's
all and this face I was going through I
was working down at the Texas Tech at
the Vietnam archive down there and we
had all these collections that had never
been looked at and this was one from a
gentleman my name of Douglas blank and
you know just stacks and boxes and boxes
of stuff and sober friday i would go up
to the to the storage area I pull a
couple boxes down look at the stuff and
and then figure out if i was going to
deal with it that day that week that
month of that year and at one friday in
1999 i came across this photograph
and I looked at it and I looked at the
image of just the woman's face and one
well it's interesting and you know going
very quickly through these things I've
looked at the back of the photograph and
it said operation passage of freedom and
refugees being boarded it shipped 1954 I
thought that's interesting you know I'd
like to look at it but I've got two more
boxes to look at I want to go home a
five so I put away but the image of the
woman's face stuck with me and I some of
you mentioned it sort of the anguish or
the hopelessness and that's really what
as I looked at it I looked at in the
sense the face had all the emotions of
the Vietnam War it has a sense of
despair but it also has a sense of hope
there's frustration there but there's
also I think as I interpret it someone
who's finally arrived or somebody's
finally escaped some who finally has an
opportunity yeah just it's just had
everything within it and that image sort
of haunted me for about two years and I
finally came back to it and and decided
to learn something about this operation
and I discovered nobody had ever written
anything on on operation passage of
freedom it was passing in books and I
think probably a few guys got some books
today you could look at the index and
see if passage of freedom is there and
they'll be a paragraph or a sentence or
a footnote and it'll be wrong it was an
incredible operation and you know after
I went got the picture again then I
looked at the little boy and I kind of
asked myself the question well why is
there a little boy and clearly an older
woman perhaps the grandmother where's
everybody else were the men of fighting
age where the women of fighting age why
is there a priest over there in the
corner and some of the garden you know
the ideas and interpretation all right
it's her via interpreter the American
guy he speaks English and he speaks high
school French the Vietnamese people they
speak Vietnamese they speak no French
into English the priest speaks
Vietnamese and Latin what just so
happens this guy is a chaplain and he
speaks Latin too so they communicated
through Latin and all these little
stories have emerged allowed of this
this image and as I learned more about
the story through this one image I
realize this was an incredible
story of the vietnam war that had been
bypassed by are looking at the war in
the 1960s to move to the next next image
so again as we go through this process
you you asked a lot of these questions
we had a lot of these observations that
I think show that the Vietnam War again
is a very complex and multi-dimensional
event in our history and also in the
history of the Vietnamese so you oh it
began in in Hanoi and Haiphong that is
in the north and Haiphong there's a sort
of a natural Harbor recalled dead duck
song and then they came down to Saigon
and a capsid chakra vongtau which is no
today and some to denying or Turan Navy
moved about 310,000 Vietnamese in 1954
255 and yet we don't know anything about
it actually was the most efficient way
to move the refugees so 310,000 removed
by navy ship of the 810,000 who left and
they went bye-bye navy ship by aircraft
and by on foot just depend on where you
lived in the country so if you live just
north of the DMZ you would simply walk
through if you could get through if they
allow you from north north to south
actually well it depends on where you
start it where you started and i would i
would make the argument this is the
first major American operation and it's
an operation that relates in it's a
humanitarian operation is actually the
largest humanitarian sealift in history
in our world's history but it's
overshadowed by by events that occur
beginning with the you know combat
troops in 65 or the advisers that get in
there interactive under Kennedy and 61
yes it was we have yeah as a result of
the 54 Geneva agreement so the three of
the articles under the agreements
covered the movement of troops north to
south south to north about 80,000 went
to the north
and 810,000 went from north to south and
actually some of those 80,000 were
rotated through American ships and
brought down intelligence to the former
viet minh or the name of the previa kong
people so yeah mostly to saigon and then
vung tau or a cop's name shock was the
overflow spot and then they were we
settled that it had a rehabilitation
resettlement rich really covered most of
Saigon northward up into the point up
into the highland area and they were
settled in in villages now incredibly
complex operation for a country that had
no infrastructure at all because of
French left them nothing so is that's
really where the Americans became
involved in the process it depends on
who you ask but most of you know there's
the combination of three different
motives for movement one was they worked
with the French and they were going to
be killed or certainly all their
possessions taken away that probably
moved about a third of the population
about a third of the population was
Catholic and they were either moved
because they needed to to flee what they
feared to be communist retribution or
they were told to leave by their their
local priest or they were encouraged to
leave by propaganda and it relate
berries and then and then the other
third are individuals who moved because
someone else moved they were part of one
of the ethnic minorities the woman
actually was part of one of the ethnic
minorities of the North that she knew
she was going to be persecuted as she
stayed in the north so yeah that's about
the other third of the group that's it
those aren't accurate numbers but
they're pretty close so there's a lot of
powerful motivations to move so you can
see a lot from the image so this is
actually the Chinese noon one of their
traditional headdresses so she knew she
was going to be in trouble but again if
you look at there's there's so much to
the image you have the again the Navy
officer in the back was purportedly
overseeing the invocation of the
refugees but in fact if he's a good
officer he's probably doing nothing but
watching allowing us junior officers to
do what they're supposed to do the image
there's a number of these images at the
website we're going to be looking at
later on the Vietnam archive website you
can see a number of these pictures and I
actually included a number from after I
finished my research but you can see
that this sort of the chaos that's
involved in the operation let's go to
the next one I think in terms of just
our art time we want to do something
similar to what we did to the first but
I think if I'm correct what we're going
to do is divide the class sort of
internet men we have a partner and hello
ed yeah judge so we can partner up so if
you just move so move to the nearest
person next to you we get a partner and
hopefully we're somewhat even if we can
have and that way if you don't know your
neighbor you can meet your neighbor so
we have one extra here right here on
extra move
leave three up here so few good we got
two groups of three so it's better if we
have two groups of two don't be shy
should we put both up once so what a
little logistic direction here the
person on the Left force on the left
raise your hand of your partner you're
going to be evaluating using the
questions and the sheet you have in
front of you the image okay the person
on the right raise your hands people on
the right you're going to be evaluating
the oral interview excerpt now you can't
cheat so if you're looking at the oral
history you have to ignore the picture
completely and vice versa and we'll know
so let me there give you five short
questions for the interview number one
who is talking and again like the
photograph we did before you just have
to do your best again these are for
folks on the right number two who is
doing the interviewing number one who is
talking number two who is interviewing
number three what is the subject of the
interview number four why is the
interview being conducted so one who is
talking to who's interviewing three what
is the subject for why is the interview
being conducted in number five and the
last one is what are the circumstances
of the interview so we're going to ask
you to do the same thing we did with the
photograph which is before you leap to
inference read study described the
interview and then you can start to
address some of the more interpretive
questions yeah list yeah to list some of
the the items the topics the phrases
that come up so give you about 10
minutes starting now sorry now i'll put
my timer on
did you need we go through the questions
again the questions again okay and
you're not allowed to share so right now
you should be working on your own
individual analysis and then you'll have
some time to put the two pieces together
put those rounds
if you're going over the top
pieces of evidence on the slide one plus
one equals what when you add the
photograph in the excerpt from the oral
interview together what do you get
that's number one so one conclusion one
sentence one interpretive statement and
the second thing is one question so one
conclusion in one question from each
pair so give you some more time to talk
with your partner and come up with that
super party you film the other
innovation yeah who wants to offer a
conclusion however tena don't let me ask
us first in terms of all the parents how
many of you could agree to a common
conclusion and how many Ray's your hands
if you could agree to a comical if
you're really comfortable with it so the
rest of you then you couldn't create
it's okay not to agree in most classes
you know but in this sense it's okay cuz
again it's very subjective in terms of
how we interpret and how we infer but if
you could that'd be great so let's get
started anyone good yeah well we
concluded that there were serious
cultural barriers between the people
carrying out this evacuation and people
who were the beneficiaries of the
evacuation in the passage discussion
about how the food that the Americans
tried to give to the Vietnamese really
was not suitable they didn't like it I
think in the photograph we see that this
naval officer is trying to assist this
boy was quite seem to understand what
the officers talking about so even even
in this humanitarian action there was
this major barrier in place and you see
evidence for your conclusion both in the
photograph and the oral history excerpt
okay so a clash of cultures that's
that's good yeah okay
so are you suggesting that there's some
tension between the photograph and then
you say more about that so it just
seemed like they set that up for some
purpose but I didn't understand but now
as we talk more about it we talked about
the two two pieces together and how they
were trying to create the people i think
they want to make the government was
showing that piece of it repeating these
people and in some sense it almost seems
like the big question is asked in
response to the photograph play with
happening here oh we tried to feed them
we could all this fish now guy from the
army would say well it takes it to least
two Navy guys to you know teach someone
how to eat so where's the army they
could do it in one but yeah so it
certainly there's a there's that that
conflict of attention between the two
they say they're a rebellion they're
standing in line getting food doesn't
really really super when I first look at
the picture doesn't look like rebellion
the least bit so seems like just from
the image oh they're getting food the
soldiers are helping them this is this
humanitarian mission but when you read
the quote that not really
okay yeah absolutely or you okay yes
so the sequence matters and dates matter
and if we think about in a history class
room I know I am careful to insist not
necessarily on the exact day but I'm
trying to make the point with students
that's not that historians are pinheaded
people who are obsessed with you know
details but it's important to know
whether something happened in 1852 or 18
55 and since I teach 19th century
history if something happened in 1875 it
probably did not cause the American
Civil War so if you want to be straight
with causes and consequences which are
really what historians are most
interested in that's why sequence
matters so if we think about this is a
great question you know was the
photograph of response at PR effort to
address a problem that had come up a
kind of cultural conflict great goals
execution runs into a ground a bit you
know was this to kind of persuade
everybody that things were really
smoother than they actually were other
conclusions I just had a curiosity in
terms of sequencing how many think the
the photograph came first so the rest of
you they would have the image come first
okay I'm not going to know the X to the
photograph came second as there is oh no
they don't go together now but in terms
of the chronology yeah of course nothing
i wouldn't go and give it away but uh ya
know it's a this is X an oral history
that's done almost 45 46 years after the
the event itself but it's the X the the
ship that that Leo was on this
particular one occurred after the the
photograph after the actual image was
taken I was good me before the image was
taken it was on his this is on the
montrose he was on the the very first
ship to to take refugees summon art so
they learned from this process and then
they had this the image of showing the
kindly Americans showing them how to
how to feed or had he had to go through
and what to do in terms of eating so
yeah it's not really a rebellion all
right think a rebellion just a strong
word it's the word that actually came to
his mind when he was thinking about this
but it's it's more of a it's a kindly
reluctance I would call it because this
occurs on almost every ship and it
really going that that first thing it's
a clash of culture not understanding
that he says fish they're sardines who
like sardines they're very salty
vietname well I do too actually but
that's beside the point but for the
Vietnamese sardine system part of the
staple diet and the cooking of the rice
the convening means have a great unique
way of cooking rice that's that's
different than certainly the the Navy so
I mean that's so it is that it's that
learning process so yeah rebellion I
think it's probably too strong of a word
well that's the word he thought of you
know in in terms of his memory oh yeah
yeah so what does that mean that it's
another whole layer absolutely you know
maybe he's an old guy down he says all
the stupid people they didn't like her
cooking but is that how soldiers reacted
at the time or is that just filtered
through his memory yeah well it's
interesting point cuz that goes into
interpretation and perspective I didn't
really I didn't see it as a very
derogatory statement
yeah yeah cut out the star daj to be
okay put a bit but it but that's the
beauty of how we interpret documents
oral histories in this case and images
because we into this time high and don't
know that when these photos absolutely
and one of the reasons why we didn't put
that identification on which we wanted
people to ask themselves as a matter of
protocol well when that was the question
that you didn't know and then we could
ask ourselves once we do knows 2001 you
know if it was 1954 how would that be
different yeah because the issue of
history and memory exactly the war the
issue about the wall and everything
about how so to me this makes a huge
difference filtered through this person
and then oh it's a big chunk of years oh
yeah yeah and there's no way to do if I
was no way to ascertain from the texts
themselves
brighton well we wanted you to fly a
little bit line it's not just a culture
which is much so this in my opinion
would be explaining right he obviously
wasn't good yeah here's a j2ee here
right now lieutenant JG that's what he
was there so they gave my interpreters
to their troops you know common order
that's right kind of like the joke was
on us that we didn't get that from the
get-go
but I also you know it's clearly
interviewed was
raises the question of whether if you
were framed this one piece yeah it was
yeah yeah it was a couple hums in hauz
there was there were no actual words I
mean no actual no no words that convey
meaning but yeah they had their own yeah
and when you go well the oral histories
are I know if you guys have a lesson on
oral histories that's another whole day
or if you've already had it okay yeah in
terms of how one approaches oral
histories and certainly with memory
because this is again 45 years after day
so I went through a longer process of
usually some some pre interview
questions and most of them offered
photographs and we would work through
those photographs or i would i would
offer them some some images but you
don't want to taint the world history by
providing a spin on how you want it to
be how you want it to happen because my
purpose was just to get their their
their emotions i had the history and
actually a lot of them forgot the
history because again this is for them
the 326 12-day period but what struck me
is amazing when i talk to these guys is
they remember detailed events of the
three days they spent with the
vietnamese 46 years after now they
couldn't remember you know anything else
about their military experience but they
remembered operation passage for freedom
and the impact it had on them their
emotional impact or the sense of moral
purpose that they they derive from the
experience they have in the vietnamese
and especially I mean maybe we'll give
this way but there's within the image
itself there's an important part that
maybe someone will come up in terms of
conclusions whether yeah
peace in science that was about research
related to non visual culture but
auditory culture and how a lot of what
we sense into the open environment is
actually auditory rather than visual and
I think that it raises when you talk
about the transcription that that
meaning is necessarily lost your
transcription correct there's a lot that
gets communicated just the way that we
speak in what we hear in the background
sounds and all of that that simply can't
be captured but adds a lot of layers of
meaning that you know are not
retrievable so I think that that's it
sort of a problem with any sort of
historical inquiry is that we aim for
similar to are getting closer but we are
bound by the limits of the tools that we
use in the media that absolutely and
then you take it a step further in terms
of the the oral presentation if you
videotape these then you can get the
hand gestures or the you know the
relaxation or the the tension that's
involved in conversations absolutely so
let's go back to to conclusions or
questions we haven't even if ya
it's actually not a posed photograph
from my understanding of it so what do
one try to answer that question or do
should we go on with more questions I
don't know we're doing for time well I
think a few moon or to anybody else want
to add on to that and respond to that or
add additional comments or questions and
I think that's I mean that's a very good
observation for the Vietnamese as they
come aboard these ships a lot of the
stories that come out of their
experiences relate to the sense of
terror anxiety and terror and as Tara
based upon propaganda that they've been
fed that the Americans are going to take
them out to see they're going to beat
them up they're going to throw them
overboard they're going to take them
these big LSTs those doors will open up
like a huge dragon and they're going to
be asked to walk through the mouth with
a dragon and there's a lot of
superstition built into that one of
there's a longer story which I can't
really sure but the gist of it is as the
Vietnamese come aboard they go through
this process of being cleaned and fed
and talking to the sailors and there's a
misunderstanding in the process as the
little girl comes aboard the ship the
biggest American sailor on the ship is
head of the welcoming committee he asks
a question in English to the Vietnamese
priest who understands a little bit
english and misinterprets a question and
she thinks that the sailor is being
angry at him with the translation is no
he's blessing you and then we go through
this process and she's dirty so he goes
and takes and helps to cleaner with soap
she's never seen soap before this
process she goes back to her mother and
the mother says what happened and I was
very worried about you and the little
girl says mommy don't worry
arakune priests was baptizing me and
they thought they saw they thought all
the sailors were priests because they
were all acting very kindly in that
association with one priests and that
they were going through this process of
American baptism and and then you know
feeding and all that process and the in
story the old lady she goes up to the
one of the sailors and she says you know
we were told lies we thought we were
going to be beaten we thought were going
to be over over over thrown overboard
you know all her possessions taken away
killed and said what happened is we come
aboard you shared your food you shared
your you know your kindness with us you
baptized us in the American Way and
you're all very kind you know gently
priests and so they end up calling
everyone on the ship Padre except for
the one man David bowling ham they
called him the bishop because he was the
one the biggest guy there but that mean
that but so we have that
misunderstanding and this is a clash of
culture this is a its language its food
its its hygiene it's everything but it's
not a clash of culture that is
necessarily a negative clash of culture
it's a very positive clash of culture in
me respects can on both sides are trying
to work out some common understanding
what's going on through language
barriers and two cultural barriers and
things of that nature that's something
we don't learn about the Vietnam War now
the question longer question does this
clash of cultures throughout the war
absolutely is it negative in many places
absolutely but salsa positive and I
think we need to understand that as you
teach the war that it's not negative
image after- internet for negative image
there's some stories and there's some
very powerful stories of individuals who
as you know the one of the talks i give
it's called a heart of gold and it's
censored a lot of Americans who go to
Vietnam because I have a heart of gold
and they do things they see problems and
they try to fix them and this that story
occurs again and again on this ship or
on all the ships that were involved so
as a tangent sorry what about questions
kind of touched on some of those but two
folks have other questions that these
two pieces of evidence raised on their
own or take in side by side yeah yeah so
what's kind of the short term and we can
imagine also the long term process of
evacuation and resettlement
yeah it would be very different we had a
triptych again she's in art history
expression on the other side of the
photograph was an excerpt from an oral
interview with one of the people who was
on the boat again they're both their
different experiences different
assumptions different ideas different
concerns Ono they had they had civilian
and military civic affairs essentially
so the United States overseas mission
and all the components to that under the
Foreign Affairs odd or foreign office
Foreign Affairs Office they went through
refugee camps and then from there went
to a resettlement camps rehabilitation
resettlement it's a huge enterprise
through the whole process Sam and then
eventually they were left in a village
with supplies and they had to make do
and there was a lot of problems with
that but that again that's a much longer
story in this process look we've already
done all this about that they'll be
stalking yeah well on that the picture
why feed the kid first I think that was
the question here so and the answer is
actually I think how American sailors
are very smart if you can capture the
kids if you can get the kids to do
something then the parents are going to
follow and that occurs again and again
on whatever thing the Americans needed
to do which I think in part is again one
of those messages of the image that I
found striking
protocols are Rory's of the other
culture would would that be appropriate
for
I think there's that the the sense of
building the trust becomes the process
is quickened when the Vietnamese elder
Vietnamese and these are grandparent age
Vietnamese see that the children are
being cared for they're being fed
they're being paid that the children are
coming back and they're telling these
stories hey this is you know they don't
understand the politics of everything or
even the clash of cultures but the
sailors are buying them everything out
the ship stores that they can get so ice
cream candy fruits vegetables everything
they have and they're giving them to the
kids because that's what sailors do when
they see people in need we see sailors
so the kids are reaping the benefits and
the older folks are seeing this and so
that in terms of eating is culture it's
not really an issue it actually quickens
the process of trust you know you know
in the three day journey that they have
ever go to bisect how long the question
was so it's a three day journey so you
know have a lot of time to build the
trust but it occurs very quickly yes
definitely
not necessarily no I mean I I know what
you mean remember this is up early on in
the in the war so this is at the end of
the first Indochina war and I think you
know the answer because why there is not
as because of just the mass confusion
that's created through the introduction
of 800 10,000 individuals who brought
with him nothing but what they could
carry on their backs into a country that
had no infrastructure because the French
colonial system provided none and they
didn't allow for the Vietnamese to to
really rise up in terms of the civil
service colonial civil service to handle
the types of issues that they would have
to do is so there's low on the priority
list there is education opportunities
but they're not in terms of re-education
to acclimate into a new culture a lot of
these folks are shuttled together in
villages that's not much longer story as
well as it's going to kind of jump in on
that that conversation we had about the
image I think raises one question among
many that we could continue to explore
in the time that we have which is how do
we perceive the American soldier in
Vietnam i sent the beginning we were
going to ask you to create a mini very
very modest visual narrative composed of
three slides and what we're going to ask
you to do is step with stephanie's help
get some more computers and also figure
out what are you going to post your
PowerPoint presentations but let's just
talk a little bit about the process so
we think about images and how they can
communicate and convey many different
things these are for images of American
soldiers in Vietnam and we could take
you know half a day on each of these
images and try to pull them apart but
what we wanted to do here is to present
a diverse set of images as an
introduction for your hands on activity
which is to go to the Vietnam center and
archive website and I'm just gonna go
through the directions and Stephanie
will get the computers out so we'll go
and we're going to be searching the
archive we're going to be looking using
the advanced search feature because what
we're interested in for our purposes
today are the images and ron has
selected some keywords so we're going to
do is divide folks into groups but
you'll use this keyword menu so I think
probably let's see how many groups we
have we've won you want to count on
there's 24 people right I think I
counted so we do groups of three yeah
okay and weigh it well we have five
groups well these for the students let's
put them in groups of three there's 15
of them right okay so 15 groups are five
groups of three and four the observers
you can join any group you want to how
about that so who are our students in
the group that's maybe good start here
yeah okay one two okay so you guys r
group one maybe can go with two people
in the right behind you okay okay that's
the second group one two three one two
three and then you folks can be a pair i
guess okay listen that's not really
fishing that'll work little okay Group
one your keywords you might want to
write these down our combat and soldier
group one to combat and troops group 3
aid and soldier group for assistance and
us and then group 5 damage and us
the year one I'm sorry good here you
folks are one well yeah this group is
one you guys are grouped to return it
yeah group 3 we're going in a zigzag I
guess one two and group five three four
five basically we do is take a look at
the archive this is a virtual Vietnam
archive is it's a massive archive
collection of documents oral histories
moving images still images artifact
images but you'll be able to go through
and you can select your own image and go
through the questions that we asked
based on the handout we gave you for the
observables inference and the just kind
of a note on format one possible way of
approaching this in the classroom I'm
sure we've had our students do
powerpoints quite often what I encourage
my students to do is to again as I said
earlier put the evidence on the slide
and put their interpretation in the
notes section so they don't give away
their interpretation by putting on the
slide people read the slide and then
don't listen to what people have to say
so that the notes section can serve both
as a place for a script and that also
makes the PowerPoint presentation
portable because you have the narration
if it wasn't done using the audio
feature it's also a good place for
students to get into the habit of
keeping track of where they find things
so I always encourage my students to put
their references in the way that they
would footnote a paper for example in
the notes section so that we could if we
go to the notes section we should be
able to get back to the image rather
than students handing something insane i
got this at ww google com no that's
we're not going to work for me to get
back to your image so give you about 15
minutes three slides might be ambitious
in that amount of time but so you try
one or two what you want to do is think
about a question do what an historian
does you have some questions already go
to the archive you have some
fakes and then you want to pick some
evidence that addresses in some fashion
your keywords and then you want to
figure out what what are you going to
say about that evidence what conclusions
can you offer what kind of questions do
you want to raise for us to consider
except you have something about the wiki
leaks to the websites that you guys
recommend it and also when you get ready
to post your PowerPoint slides that you
have made if you log into the class web
we've made a folder that says holder
with projects for powerpoint and you can
just upload them to that pile just be
sure to name anything that you upload
with your name in the title so that we
know you have all presentation once just
to clarify for the purposes of this
activity we're going to ask you to use
this particular archive which is on that
list of resources and then you can go
use some of those other resources later
on because the keywords that are on
selected relate particularly to this
archive and I assume that most people
are probably pretty familiar with being
able to take an image that you find on
the web and put it in your PowerPoint
presentation but do have any trouble
with that just holler and we'll come
someone will help you out with that
you